Scott Van Pelt joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Scotty I'm
good be the US Open is to eat off rich
Dido u.s. open feed off golf clap yeah I
just gave you a golf clap I really did
feel good about a minute you too man
Scott you got mad mashed potatoes get in
the hole
so the wind she's a she is a blowin out
there on strong Island right now how do
you check out the first I guess half of
the first round Scott what's your take
on what we're seeing so far well it
that's it right in a nutshell this is a
I mean it's it's as much as a US a US
Open can be like a seaside links like
the Open Championship because it sits
right there on Long Island the winds
howling and it's an exposed golf course
with where the greens are hard to keep
it's hard to keep your approaches in the
right places and the balls rolling off
and it's a disaster that there's many
cliches in the game one of which is you
can't win it and first day but you can
lose it and right now players like Jason
Day who a lot of people liked and jordan
Spieth and I mean I could run through a
litany Rory McIlroy these guys are like
eight nine ten over par in the first day
and it Dustin Johnson Joe Justin Thomas
and Tiger get ready to go as you
mentioned here at this hour so unless
the wind dies down I don't know what I
don't know how much better anyone's
going to do they've been 1-under par you
shoot anything around even today and you
have played your butt off now but the
fact though that this is an old-school
US Open course one that has seen the US
Open before do you think that's a reason
why we're not hearing many complaints
about course set up if this was a
chambers Bay for instance there might be
some sort of complaints it's an
interesting that's an interesting point
but I don't think it's that so much as
just that I think everybody is the wit
doesn't blow the fairways here generous
enough that you can shoot under par I
mean look pearcy shot 1-under it looks
like Ian Poulter can shoot one I guess
he's got a putt to maybe get to 2 but I
think the complaints and we'll hear what
guys have to say when they come off but
I don't think you'll hear people
complain just because they understand
that if the wind really
this golf course and big numbers can
happen I guess the key will be for the
USGA is if you know it's going to be
windy you've got a vertical of course
and field term how you set it up so I
don't know if they set it up today
thinking it would be windy or if they
fit it up today because they're still
pissed off that last year everybody
their mother shot 1500 plus they put it
they you know they want to extract their
pound of flesh I don't know I don't know
what the what the reaction will be at
the end of the day it's just obvious
that any as I said anything around level
pars is great great score yeah I mean do
you give us a little bit of insight in
that Scott I mean does the USG sit or a
Jewett GA sit around and stew over the
final numbers and say okay let's get
that stamp like it's like it's a sheet
of glass when it's all said sure don't
know why about it and they'll say we're
not trying to protect pard we don't care
what the score is but that's just that's
over the years it's just been they've
shown that that's not the case he'll the
last time they played at Shinnecock they
killed the golf course and I mean right
that's not like a metaphor like the
entire golf course was dead on Sunday
and and if you dropped a match on the
first tee the entire 18 would have been
on fire in two minutes because
everything was dead and they don't they
don't love the idea that you know double
digits under par was their championship
it doesn't typically happen and then
last year you know everybody kept going
and try and think it was Fleetwood and
buy an arm and all these guys were
double digits under because this the
course just wasn't there was no death no
defense for the for what they could do
and that's just not what the US Open
typically is that also is not a golf
course where they'd ever played before
so Shinnecock as we saw I think it was
for under the Goosen shot that year but
he putted like a a space alien the year
that he won he made he made like 5-1
putts from 20 feet he was a joke so you
know long story yes they don't want to
see you shoot low scores they'll say
they don't care but that that is that's
a lot Scott Van Pelt from the world wide
leader midnight edition to SportsCenter
love watching him here on the Rich Eisen
show and
I think I've shown remarkable restraint
so far you've been on about four or five
minutes I haven't asked you a
point-blank question about Tiger Woods
Scott I think I've done said I'm just
I'm kind of patting myself on the back
right now you should to fire away like
you now take the gloves off what do you
learn about I don't know I don't know I
just wanted to say his name
it's so sad so sad but I've devolved
into right now Scott I'm just going low
hanging fruit but I guess let's let's go
with what sort of shot you you think
he's got this time it's it's the it's
the giant question mark that I I I'm
just guessing if I say one thing or
another I if he if he hits the ball tee
to green he did at the Memorial where he
played great great golf except for
putting then he's gonna have a great
he'll have an opportunity he could he
could contend if fairways are wide
enough that I don't think that's gonna
be an issue for him I would think he'd
play well um I got a bunch of buddies
that told me that they were the prop bet
they're bad now he's missed the cut he's
missed the shot Michael I mean if you
want to take a stab at it fine go ahead
but I think he's played well enough this
year in total to think he could contend
but literally sitting here watching the
wind blow and watching these guys that
are like Jason Day and McIlroy SP shoot
these giant numbers and I just would
shrug and tell you I had no words the
idea what he's going to do it's being
part I was better answer no no like I I
want to be cast I want to give you the
goods and I don't feel like I'm giving
any goods right now that I'm just
cutting you like this shrug emoji but
you've got enough that I mean anything
else that you'd say would be would be
alive Scott and honestly the question
why that question wasn't even that good
either I'll be honest all I'll criticize
myself question wasn't that great it
would be icy icy Midas questions
answered hey let's put it all together
and hopefully it'll cancel each other
out there was just an a in a
broadcasting moment for both of us
how did the Cape's victory sit with you
Scott give me give me some mid-atlantic
region voice to this long long wait
finally ending it was spectacular man
and and I've been as honest and to use
the word of the day I've been as
transparent as I could be about the
fact that I'm I'm not from October until
April like sweating out the games with
the Panther today I just don't have the
time I don't have the intellectual and
emotional energy but I really love to
stay on the cop and I always have and so
I went to game for the one that they 162
and it was so much fun to be in DC and
see the atmosphere and see the energy of
the place and I'm telling you rich and I
mean look I grew up there I got to go I
saw the Redskins win and the Reds get on
that town there's no line about that but
what the Capitals did in winning beating
the penguins along the way and then in
winning the first Cup and then how they
celebrated in the city with the city
with this non-stop just joyful drunken I
mean it was not it was that's well put
that's exactly what it was it's made
them like a forever team in DC they have
been totally embraced and it become
beloved in a way that I didn't even know
hockey could be loved in DC but it's
because of the way Ovechkin let him it's
because of how much fun they had the
process and after and it's it's it's
been amazing to me to see how DC has has
just exploded with love for the Capitals
it was it was it was so much freakin fun
yeah man and you're right it's fun
watching these guys like we're just
showing video ho some of the celebration
you know TJ oshi for whatever reason
pulling his jersey over his face and
then pouring a beer through the jersey
ovett you just I mean you know Ovechkin
himself I mean just watching him with
pure joy I don't think it's been a full
week I don't has he given up the cup to
anybody else yet does that happen
he gave it to Backstrom's right off the
bat and then ever since then I think
mostly I mean it's been in his bed you
know the pictures did babies been
everywhere and god only knows what will
happen to it and with it during the time
that the Capitals have it but I mean he
from the second he rent one onto the ice
like that that look on his face has
never changed it looks like a little kid
on Christmas and you know he look you
know this you follow the sport he wasn't
a good player he's a
great player he's a 600 gold guy and he
carried the weight of yet but they
always failed missing that and he go on
the Conn Smythe he was everything a
captain was supposed to be and then he's
you know then he put his body and a
fountain in his face in the keg stands
and you know he was uh he did what
you're supposed to do he was new to the
captain Oh captain my captain yes I
became a legend guy became a legend I
know and he just looks like an extra
from Game of Thrones or from one of
those Capital One commercials right
where the beard yesterday really yeah
I don't even know we let play you know
how that word clears you know the beard
yeah yeah it's right off comes the
playoff beard playoffs are over and it's
funny how you said that too cuz you know
about how you would fully admit that
you'll surf into the hockey season when
the Cup playoffs begin and holidays my
Hannah be one of those two you know very
rarely was I told by Sports Center
management don't say that again in my
seven years they're the one-china was
told alike maybe you want to lay off
that like so it was like a half don't do
that again was on the opening night of
the hockey season when ESPN had the
rights to the NHL non-stop image there
was no wall to wall Steve Levy Palooza
highlight it was Ottawa versus who the
heck knows and I it was a tie and I said
Ottawa is now tied with twelve other
teens for the eighth and final playoff
spot in the Eastern Conference and I was
I was so proud of myself yeah maybe you
don't want to say that anymore you know
it's just it's a long season you know
what I mean I did
yeah I've been policed for other things
but they were they were it was I was I
was way way deeper into the fescue than
you were without the emotional fescue
emotional fest yeah I don't know like
whatever it was it was me fescue it
might have been whatever it's been a few
times maybe maybe may want to go down
that road I did open a Sports Center
talking about how much money over it's
made in the Disney deal that when it
and then that was like almost like a
Network movie moment right there or
don't mess with the noises in nature
that was one of those but anyway I can I
give you the best when I got called in
quick please you might recall an SNL
short that involved a song about a
Christmas present that you could give it
correct and he there was a period of
time on on SportsCenter we would put
sound of you know an analyst or an
athlete into a highlight and it was it
was you know they called it the sock box
and it that the picture would pop up on
the screen and we did it with with dick
bye town I said man I said it's our nut
box
and brilliant I thought was really
brilliant and there were some who
disagree that was my point that was my
point is it was a soft box and dick by
Tao was in it so I didn't I did I did
say his last name I felt like that was
an important distinction to make so I
thought the Emmy was coming that week it
did not smell and you got back to your
desk yeah I don't I don't even recall
how it happened I just recall that there
was a meeting and I got called in and it
was conversation and it might be
something a permanent file like third
grants on your permanent record
I'll be there at midnight tonight doing
a shout out look forward to it it's Andy
North still involved in the coverage is
he still oh yeah he's he's there at
Shinnecock with Tom Rinaldi we said it's
a fox production these days which is uh
it it's odd to watch someone else do it
because we did it for so many years but
it's these are long days man so it's fun
to sit up and just let someone else do
the heavy lifting but Andy and Tom
Rinaldi will be there okay I'm sure
we'll be talking about day one from
Shinnecock well I'm sure Tom Rinaldi
will introduce the only two ways you can
introduce Andy North you know that right
Scott it's two times 51 weeks of the
year he's two-time US Open champion Andy
North but this week Andy
North 2-time winner of this event that's
true that's it see now but no one's
gonna complain about this is factually
correct as dick by Tao being in a box
correct
take care at Scott Van Pelt check him
out tonight midnight Eastern Sports
Center the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience